pues según elementos comunicados en una
nota oficial de la cancillería italiana
el embajador italiano en república
democrática del congo luca atanasio se
encontraba a bordo de un vehículo que
hacía parte de un convoy de las naciones
unidas en la zona de la ciudad de goma
en congo con el viajaba un carabinero
militar italiano el convoy fue atacado
no se sabe todavía por parte de qué
grupo fue atacado él en el hecho el
embajador y su acompañante en los dos
italianos murieron la prensa italiana
evoca un intento de secuestro de este
convoy el ministro italiano de asuntos
exteriores
witty dimaggio ha reaccionado
oficialmente a través de un comunicado
oficial en el cual deplora lo sucedido y
manifiesta su profundo dolor por la
muerte del embajador y de su acompañante
seguramente en las próximas horas
habremos tendremos más detalles sobre
las circunstancias de este drama
natalia complemento su información
diciendo que esta ciudad de goma es una
ciudad fuertemente disputada por grupos
rebeldes están
frontera con uganda y ruanda donde
justamente hay también disputas con
grupos rebeldes por ser una zona minera
donde extracción de minas y de manera
ilegal y es una zona fuertemente
custodiada por los convoyes de la
organización de naciones unidas una
noticia en desarrollo más adelante
volveremos con ustedes romá si hay más
reacciones por parte del gobierno
italiano o del organismo de naciones
unidas gracias por este reporte desde
roma natalia